Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui dans ScienceClic, la Matière Baryonique
La matière est tout ce qui possède une
masse.
Tout dans l'univers est fait de matière,
mais il en existe différents types.
Les planètes, la Terre, les êtres
vivants, et la plupart des choses
que nous côtoyons sont composées de
minuscules particules de matière,
les atomes.
Les atomes cependant, ne sont pas des
composantes fondamentales.
En effet ils sont eux-mêmes composés d'un noyau,
qui est fait de protons et de neutrons,
autour duquel orbitent des électrons.
Les protons et les neutrons font
partie d'une catégorie de particules
que l'on appelle les baryons.
Ainsi la matière qui est faite d'atomes
est composée de baryons.
C'est donc cette forme de matière, faite d'atomes,
que l'on appelle matière baryonique.
A première vue la matière baryonique
semble être la forme de matière la plus courante.
En effet, les atomes qui la
composent,
en formant des molécules et des assemblages complexes,
sont à la base de tout ce qui est visible dans l'univers.
Cependant, en réalité, la matière
baryonique ne représente que 5% du cosmos.
Il existe donc des formes de matières
que l'on appelle matières exotiques,
qui ne sont pas composées d'atomes, mais qui
représentent la majeure partie de l’univers.
Parmi les formes de matière exotique,
on trouve par exemple la matière noire.